as markets assess the fallout from the
federal federal reserve stepped up fight
against inflation kirsten joyce
connected with paula pant she is the
host of afrod anything podcast out of
new york uh to talk about some of the
investor concerns today absolutely so
what happened today is that target and
walmart put out some earnings reports
that
made investors panic essentially what
those reports said
was that
people don't have as much money to spend
on
discretionary items toys and games and
the thing make up the things you love to
buy at target and walmart
because of inflation people are spending
more of their money on groceries and gas
and so because of that they're spending
less on discretionary items meaning that
companies like target and walmart aren't
making as much money
meaning that investors aren't willing to
pay as much for those stocks and when
that happens the stock market goes down
and then paula just this tuesday the fed
said that u.s central bank will be
raising interest rates until there's
evidence that inflation is in retreat
should we expecting more of what we
experience today
there is certainly a risk of that
any time that the fed moves to
curb inflation by raising interest rates
they
necessarily trigger the risk of a
recession when the fed raises interest
rates what they're trying to do is take
money out of the system and they do that
by making money more expensive to borrow
supply and demand when something's more
expensive people get less of it so if
money is more expensive to borrow people
borrow less so they spend less
and that means that there's always the
risk of a recession so that's why the
fed has what's known as a dual mandate
to both handle inflation and
simultaneously
try to not trigger a recession
and her advice for the long-term
investor stay the course you're in it
for the long haul only really an issue
what happened today if you need the
money today for those who are retired if
you don't have enough cash reserves so
you can get a part-time job just to get
you through the next six months until
your portfolio starts to bounce back and
if you look at the past century plus it
always does